Miami is experimenting with a plan to
move all their homeless people onto an
island dude that's a great idea man I
guess it's Virginia Island which is like
off the key somewhere
um it hasn't started yet but they're
they're putting it in motion they're
gonna put them all there I guess what
first of all Miami has become it is so
there's so much wealth down there that
this is the kind of thing you're gonna
start seeing man yeah yeah and then
people tourists are gonna they're gonna
be tourist boats going out there to see
them I I would go to that [ __ ] Island
yeah like I [ __ ] Miami I don't feel good
about all the glitz Gucci all that [ __ ]
man let's go to the [ __ ] homeless
Island yeah right and get malaria or
whatever you know they get the public
diseases there oh yellow fever
everything they have yeah yeah but then
there's gonna be probably like a gift
shop or something on the island you're
gonna be able to like get like a like a
picture taken with a homeless guy right
or like like a Ewok statue made out of
meth scabs
you know they can make art you know what
I mean like folk folks they are yeah you
know what I mean yeah I mean like you
know a tooth necklace
right yeah yeah yeah yeah dude that'd be
cool that gift shop dude a f if we got
to run a gift shop on a homeless Island
yeah but dude you're gonna have you know
those crap if there's not dry if they're
not also ship drugs out there they are
gonna swim back oh dude you would have
to you're right what would you need to
do to keep them happy I think you'd have
to put up barricades and hide drugs in
the middle of the island but would you
helicopa I would drop them in yeah right
wouldn't you do that I think you'd have
to yeah just helicopter and what like
you know weed for sure yeah yeah I mean
alcohol for sure opiums but how much is
this gonna cost it sounds expensive and
especially they're gonna stay alive for
so long out there in the summer which
they should they all want them to stay
alive yeah but yeah if you don't have
proper program stuff out there they're
just out there on the island they're
gonna be [ __ ] killing each other dude
it's gonna be like Zelda breath of the
wild yeah or that movie um
um Escape From New York uh you ever see
that movie
what you've never seen Escape From New
York I haven't seen that and I just
couldn't watch the boys I tried I didn't
like it yeah but escaping oh God you
have to watch it okay can I tell you the
premise real quick it's much like yes
it's basically in the future right and
Kurt Russell plays Snake Eyes okay and
basically in the future New York City is
now one large prison so they just built
a wall around New York City and all
everyone that's a convict and gang
member they just live there and that's
it they just you know so like when
you're there you have to survive oh wow
right but I think it's going to be a lot
like that where you you put build a
gigantic wall around the island you have
to ship you know I mean [ __ ] food or
whatever and it's just like
Anything Goes
anything goes man
you think it's going to be scary for
those people that live there
I mean if there's no clinics or [ __ ]
police or you know I mean if they just
let them run wild
they're gonna open 50 to 100 tiny homes
uh and then they're gonna have Services
there they say but they don't go into a
lot of specifics but there are going to
be like 50 to 100 tiny homes they were
experimenting with this in Venice too if
you're familiar tiny homes yeah it's a
tiny hole man like the Little Red Wings
over there yeah they're supposed to be
hide and go seek or something yeah yeah
I would put something like a creation
juice Place yeah right did they get acai
Bowl you're like you gotta do something
healthy like you know like ginger shots
right I would have one right if they
want to get healthy
right Ginger shots yeah yeah yeah you're
a man some homeless yeah we grasp we
grasp you know yeah I think you gotta
have crops for them to work you need to
have some sort of farming system
sustainable food yeah um they're gonna
have severe Sunburn and skin I don't
know I but also I could see them filming
it and putting it on some kind of closed
circuit television and we all pay for it
it's an extra live feed type of thing
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying
that's where we're headed it's getting
weird I mean we're literally reading an
article they're gonna put homeless
people on an island wow that's how
Australia got started man they put
criminal people on an island yeah that's
what they did right and it's great now
so maybe it is for the best
wow you didn't have children out there
and stuff oh dude yeah if you don't
there's you don't see them grow up but
they have them you know yeah yeah all
right so we could have but maybe this is
a good idea and in California what do we
do Catalina yeah or the desert Catalina
is a [ __ ] dump let's put him out
there yeah they make it cool with that
Carousel or whatever but yeah yeah it
doesn't feel like you're even on an
island I know it's so weird this is like
[ __ ] Irvine but like surrounded by
water but doesn't like there's no like
tropical trees it's just like Irvine
Hill it's terrible yeah it's like a sh
it's like it's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ]
it's one shitty section of a zoo there's
bison there there's no real Native
Americans they charge you to get out
there I hate it there's couples breaking
up on the way there that went that are
going for their honeymoon it's [ __ ]
unbelievable [ __ ] Catalina
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one